aujourd'hui j'annonce que le
gouvernement du québec va attribuer à la
ville de montréal un montant de 250
millions de dollars sur cinq ans québec
ouvre les vannes 45 millions de dollars
chaque année sur cinq ans sont prévus
pour l' embauche de policiers 5 millions
pour l' embauche d'intervenants sociaux
afin d'alléger les interventions des
policiers j'ai toujours dit si faut en
faire plus on va en faire plus le
gouvernement sera au rendez vous la
ville de montréal égalisera le nombre
d'embauchés par québec l'objectif avoir
450 nouveaux policiers dans les rues de
montréal d'ici cinq ans montréal de ce
rapport le terrain je décris mineurs la
fraternité des policiers avaient
critiqué valérie plantes l'accusant de
fermer les yeux ou la rétention des
policiers à montréal
aujourd'hui elle a salué l'effort du
gouvernement du québec de montréal et du
spvm pour augmenter les effectifs
policiers et rétablir le sentiment de
sécurité de la population
certains se questionnent sur la
faisabilité de ces objectifs sans
compter que les départs à la retraite
pourraient être nombreux dans les
prochaines années ça fait quand même
beaucoup de monde trouvait justement
est-ce que
[Musique]
suffire est ce que
d'autres voudraient voir comme investi
directement pour aider à réduire la
criminalité chez les jeunes nous on veut
que des sommes soient engagées pour
qu'on puisse rejoindre travail et
accompagner des jeunes qui ont des
dossiers criminels des jeunes qui
sortent de prison des jeunes qui ont des
problèmes de toxicomanie
une entente a aussi été conclu avec
l'école nationale de police 72 nouveaux
policiers devraient gradué de l'école
d'ici mars 2023 et rejoindre les rangs
du spvm au moins d'un an ce sont 450
millions de dollars qui ont été investis
par québec pour lutter contre la
violence par armes à feu ici ma isabel
rochât radio canada montréal